il avait été condamné à un an de prison
dont quatre mois avec sursis lors d'un
premier jugement la cour d'appel
confirme cette décision
l'oncle et la tante de l'adolescente
tondu sont reconnus coupables de ce
geste et de coups portés sur la jeune
fille
je suis très satisfaite pour ma jeune
cliente qui attendait cette décision
avec impatience et cette décision
corrobore tout ce que cette jeune fille
a pu déclarer depuis le départ quant à
la participation des quatre adultes à
savoir ses parents son oncle et sa tante
dans le cas d agression que la dénoncer
la cour d'appel a ajouté un stage de
citoyenneté pour l'oncle et la tante le
couple renoncent à se pourvoir en
cassation
il est aux actes vont effectuer de
petits foyers et nous verrons bien qu'il
me prend l'intérieur envisagera de se
dire le fera pour révoquer lors une
réfugiée que les échos
gérald darmanin avait hâte et
l'expulsion des parents de l'adolescente
vers la bosnie herzégovine en octobre
dernier la jeune victime a été prise en
charge par l'aide sociale à l'enfance
elle pourra demander un titre de séjour
à sa majorité